[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
the careful boys where we keep you
careful here guys
hey so bart said he's got a little story
what's up what's up bart are you going
to introduce gilbert nope sorry all
right let's uh hey roll it back roll
back
absolutely
this guy's the most professional here
back steve retake bring back stephen
how exactly friday is it yeah action hey
welcome back to camera boys guys where
i'm super careful and i introduce the
hosts and oh i'm the host [ __ ] bring
back steve yeah
steve steve steve that's what you get
when you hire a guy who dances for money
i know first of all don't forget don't
attack my profession you want him to
host the show he's dances for money for
a living he just learned that gilbert's
a junior he shakes it for dollars
does he not am i lying is that a lie
focus guys
all right give it up for our guest
gilbert jr
all right now [ __ ] the guest all right
bart you said you had a story so i have
advice for everyone
don't ever get [ __ ] coffee from
terribles ever i thought you were
telling everyone to get it i know i
loved it before wait that's the story
that's the story yeah the story was like
we all talked about it everyone's like
yeah
right and this guy he loves gas station
[ __ ] coffee right so out of all the
places he's like my favorite coffee shop
you guys wouldn't believe this it's a
terrible gas station in las vegas and
i'm like well the place is called
terrible what do you expect so that one
yeah but the build-up bart you're
telling everyone not to get gas station
coffee no so
so that he gave us the moral of the
story the terrible's that one has a
special place in my heart but one the
[ __ ] chevron off the 15 with the
hundred pumps you know what i'm talking
about oh yes actually 100 pounds that
one sabotages you so i got coffee
yesterday cause i'm driving here at
night right i'm trying to stay awake so
i got coffee and first of all the lid it
doesn't fit that good that's good so i'm
always like this is going to be our
greatest video ever i'm already serious
it doesn't fit wait for it to wait for
the no it doesn't fit that good so i'm
like securing it making sure it fits
good right
i get in the car here it goes here drive
about 30 minutes and i need to get some
coffee yeah yeah
yeah
when i'm drinking it nothing is going
into my mouth oh [ __ ] nothing and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on and it
starts burning and i'm like oh [ __ ] it's
all over my jacket so i take it off i
take off my jacket and my pants because
my pants is soaked and it's hot why'd it
take you that long how are you taking
this alive you wearing snap-on pants
he's like i'm 70 miles per hour on the
road i take off my clothes but it's like
first i stared away fly fishing gear
then i pulled i pulled over and then i
took off my jacket i took off my pants
and i don't want the coffin to soak into
my seats
and then i'm like okay [ __ ] just
naked attempt number two i love who's
talking to the cops tip number two naked
i'm driving now
i take a drink again it happens again
so now it's all over my shirt i'm like
[ __ ] so i take the shirt off so
i'm not just driving with my hat
my underwear and shoes
and then you know when you're on the
road for like three hours you forget
what's going on right i'm just like cool
i'm in the zone you forgot that you're
naked
and all your coffee's gone oh i'm
[ __ ] i'm zoned into robert malone on
joe rogan i'm like what the [ __ ] is all
this [ __ ] going on he's getting
cancelled for this [ __ ] you know what
the hell is going on i pull up it is a
three hour podcast it is right i pull up
to uh just pull up to
gio's mom's house
and underwear
in underwear and i come out and she
looks at him she starts laughing and
then the two cholos behind me are
looking at me weird too and i that's
when i clicked i'm like oh [ __ ] i forgot
i did not close up
yo that's wild man bro it's not that
wild if you know him if you walked in
here like that we'd be like hey bart
good morning
he's walked in here multiple times
without a shirt but don't get that
terrible coffee because it has a [ __ ]
gap right here dude what did you learn
though how did you do that twice yeah
that's how you don't stand there and
just go like okay how does this work no
it's never happened to me before you
gotta get back on the road and be like
oh god damn it happened again i thought
it would have fixed myself the second
time dude i don't know i [ __ ] i i did
the thing i did you know oh [ __ ]
all
just that's right right he's doing prop
cops
it might be bart it might be bart admit
it just 10 minutes you said all that
have to do
no
it's gonna be like the snakes on a
spring
this is something that i experienced
coming back from vegas okay and i gotta
say to kind of pick up what you're
saying all right don't use rest stop
bathrooms
which one did you pull it what's wrong
with that terrible all of them all of
them nothing so gas stations are
adorable you know how you all think rest
stop bathrooms would be would be fine oh
no don't use breaststop bathrooms there
you go i never would have thought they'd
be fine no just [ __ ] that everyone
already knows
and it's not even the terrible's fault
[ __ ] i don't know solo's fault it's
the cops oh dude doesn't everyone's
[ __ ] check that [ __ ] to make sure
it's it's secure if it's wobbly you're
like that's kind of weird bro you gotta
press all the way around i did the thing
you gotta press all the way around i'm
gonna explain to you with his eyes i did
the [ __ ] thing
look and then i [ __ ] did the thing
yeah yeah see
and then [ __ ] right when i get in the
car go like this nothing goes in the
mouth everything comes down here you're
also like the whole did you like smash i
know right you smash and warp the
[ __ ] oval
and the [ __ ] krispy kremes there
isn't even krispy kremes what is it
there's a krispy kreme section and i put
in my mouth i thought i was gonna melt
and they're just dry they're probably
stale he bit it it's just beef jerky ah
not again
the beef jerky trick the donuts at gas
stations aren't that good you guys but
this has krispy kremes on it but is that
terrible i thought it was chevron
chevron terrible i don't know different
man this whole story is fake bankrupt
the wrong business with the story
chevrolet cameras call them and check
the cameras they got a white castle
there though they do oh yeah yeah yeah
do you guys like white castle i like it
rated right yeah overrated
it tastes like the microwavable ones if
you're if you're on narcotics i think
you like it narcotics is the word to use
for that one and the narcotic i think oh
my gosh across the board when did
everybody start drinking coffee
is everybody like a coffee everyday
person i don't drink coffee yeah i drink
off every day when i was a kid yeah when
you were a kid i started seven first
time was at a bank and i could not oh i
got banked coffee too what bank coffee
because you know back in the day they
don't have atms right and then so like
if your mom wants to deposit some [ __ ]
is gonna take four hours yeah so [ __ ]
you're just wandering around doing
nothing and you're like you're a kid
yeah you see coffee you start pouring 50
creams in it yeah at that point you're
drinking milk that's tinted brown dude
does this video the careful boys go in
on coffee i know right the cop there's a
war against coffee
coffee
coffee
take that
[Laughter]
when did you have some crazy coffee
tell us that time my craziest cup of
coffee
did the whole build up to this bar i
thought he was going to say some crazy
stuff
we all did in the mornings just sounding
like hey anybody got something to share
we're doing another off the record but i
got a story i got a story it happened
yesterday i spilled coffee brew we make
it a hot topic
you'll make the most mundane [ __ ] very
interesting though yeah that was pretty
good yeah that was pretty good i
wouldn't listen to anybody else coffee
spill story i mean it's like an unsolved
mystery because you still don't know why
that happened yeah see if you i know why
it happened it's cause of [ __ ] bark
and then i was uh since i was naked and
i needed to pee i just peed back into
the cup because it was cold outside i
didn't want to go outside it was [ __ ]
cold it was so i just peeped
and then he spilled
it ah there's pee on my chest
and this beef jerky doughnut
we almost didn't he was your partner
yeah like that's the most intense part
you weren't planning to say that part i
just peed in the truck guaranteed geo
wasn't in the car
just back over there
so you have to when you have to pee
while driving that's your go-to is just
to pee in the car no usually if i have
clothes on and i'm not cold then i can
go outside and pee like a normal human
all my clothes were off and it was cold
so i was just [ __ ] i was pee in the
[ __ ] terribles cup
yo this is
i like it
steve have you been your cup on the way
over here
no i hold it like i'm an adult
yeah so i just wait until it's time to
go and then i go
do you go to a rest stop bathroom
i got coffee spilled they were almost
like i liked ryan's better ryan's was
when who was the gayest dentist you had
wait right explain it that was a problem
that was his prompt but i mean rate your
dentist from gayest to gay yeah how gay
was i'm gay yes
what are the attributes that i would
have to look for because i don't even
know all right sister gabe who's like
they try to make out with you
take your baseline dip okay baseline
baseline dentist give us a ballpark give
us a spectrum i don't know but my
podiatrist is um
uh like i wouldn't even i wouldn't know
what you have a podiatrist
you don't hear about those anymore
dude i got i got warts on my feet that i
had to take oh
yeah
and then um i've never even seen a
podiatrist my uncle's a bit hey just for
the audience what's a podiatrist
podiatrist is a foot doctor man and they
always open the conversation with let's
see them feet
let me see those toes that's standard
yeah that's what they teach you in
school
you said let me see them feet
let me see their feet or they say put
them up
that's called bedside manner yeah that's
it that's basically
that's the doctor term so i don't know
his sexual preference
but every time i go in there
he starts the sentence with hmm
joseph
today's video is brought to you by
audible all right so you know i've been
going on road trips i've been doing that
a lot
and so there's only so much talking you
can do there's only so much listening to
music you can do after a while it's
beautiful but three four hours you gotta
kill that time somehow and i like to be
productive right yeah so um we started
actually listening to audiobooks
and
educational podcasts but there's this
one book that i always wanted to share
rich dad poor dad right
and so thank goodness for audible
because we can get on the road plug this
in play and we just chill and it's like
a three four hour like listen so for the
whole trip we just listen to that and it
also makes for good conversation because
we can pause and just be like yo what
did you think about that chapter and you
know how would you approach it so it's
pretty dang awesome and so if you're
doing road trips if you're out there on
like long drives like you're coming here
from vegas and stuff right i think
audible is just a sick way to like not
only learn and be productive but also
like enjoy many different types of media
aside from just like music yeah what's
dope about audible it's a pretty much a
one-stop shop for all kinds of audio
entertainment in one app so you got
podcasts you got audio books they have
shows so pretty much whatever you want
to make your ears feel good on long road
trips they have it they even have like
comedy so you can like laugh you don't
have to like it doesn't have to be that
serious and educational that's just what
i like yeah it's literally your one-stop
shop so what's dope about audible is
number one there's thousands of podcasts
up there and if you want to listen to an
audiobook you can listen to one title
per month and the best part is new
members get to try it free for 30 days
so you can just give it a listen check
out the entire library and see if it's
right for you so if you want to check
out this one-stop shop for all your
audio entertainment go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 that's audible.com off the
record or text off the record to 500 500
and check it out
check it out
is he philippines he feels like a joke
no he's like taiwanese or something and
then i hear him in the other room and he
has this very soft way of speaking like
this
and i'm just like bro
you're very
you're comforting but also creepy at the
same time because it's very asmr his
voice is calming yeah when he's talking
about award this one
about 10 um
off this one is about 80 huh what are
the discounts no he's talking about the
the wart like how many percent off it is
like
more removal i thought i was a black
friday sale yeah yeah
i was like what's the context what does
that mean i'm so confused looks like
you're podiatrist he's your gayest
dentist yeah that's definitely
wait do they make good money i've never
been to a foot doctor yo so my bill i
had uh two little warts on my foot for
two [ __ ] years right hey why
i didn't know there was oh i thought it
was a callus
yeah well what's the difference between
a callus and a wart isn't a word like
green and bleeding no no um
i think ward is like uh like a fungus or
a virus that's like uh like a skin virus
and it's just stuck there and it could
it could be contagious if you have a
foot cut you could get a wart there too
and you could have them for up to two
years
before you go to the doctor you know two
years ago i swear to god i thought it
was just a callous because
you come too early
has it been two years get the [ __ ] out
of here six more months man
you want to do it you got 30 more days
turn business away at the podiatry
center i had to hit up bart's cousin i
was like because he's trying to be a
foot doctor right so i took a picture of
my foot and i was like hey bro what is
this a callus or a wart and he goes wart
you have to go to a foot talking
wait two years ago yeah wait two years
minimum wait two years for me to
graduate and then uh come see me
actually do not this is the most useless
[ __ ] profession in the world right
because i went to say that to his cousin
yeah man that's his dream
well maybe maybe if you have like [ __ ]
up ankles and bones or whatever right
before wart i didn't realize that you
could do this [ __ ] at home right so what
he ended up doing was i went there that
fool scraped it out with like a knife
and then yeah he put like some medicine
that you could buy over the counter to
seal it tiger ball
yeah it's like a it's like a it's like a
liquid
it's a sealer right i went and i had my
insurance so i thought it covered it so
i went there three times this bill came
out to almost a thousand bucks i got to
pay 300 bucks out of pocket so i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this i could have
scraped my [ __ ] with a knife at home and
not medical advice for anybody who has
what dietrich are [ __ ] scammed
useless profession my uncle was a
podiatrist was see because he knew it's
a stab i mean so he left the game he
left the game for that reason
he kept saying he's like i keep scamming
these people he left again because he
was winning
he was making money for his boss and he
was like dude [ __ ] this and he left he's
like i'm out
he made his offer he's a bus driver the
boss he's a bullet traveler imagine
getting imagine paying a thousand bucks
to [ __ ] get yourself for real wow bro
i had ingrown toenails i had to go to
podiatrist and the whole time he's just
talking to me about his [ __ ] car
collection
because he he had like a bunch he
handles well he looks
yeah he's just like talking about hey
how long how long did you wait two years
uh i didn't i didn't oh yeah i waited a
while yeah i was walking around with an
ingrown toenail for a [ __ ] while but
until it like basically every time i put
my shoe on i would have tears in my eyes
and i was like i gotta go to the doctor
oh [ __ ]
that's your threshold i'm crying every
day yeah yeah yeah
he's a real man
[Laughter]
just go to the doctor and i'm like i got
this baby they're scammers yeah
do you do you feel scammed though tell
me the truth you [ __ ] feel scared
right i feel scared i do feel scared
wait even on an ingrown toenail well
what was your procedure for fixing that
i see that [ __ ] on [ __ ] youtube and
stuff like that i've seen those dudes i
could have got a [ __ ] screwdriver and
pop that out for you this is a tool i
could have gotten amazon
right i'm not an idiot there you have it
there's my procedure right there like
liquid nitrogen whatever yeah
they freeze it and they flick it off or
something they numb the area it was
pretty sick very scientific where they
flick them out costs a lot of money
right you gotta like [ __ ] actually
numb the area yeah but why can't he
afford a bunch of sports cars though oh
say his full name
doctor
i don't remember i definitely don't
remember octavius
it's a scam dude no this is one of those
videos where fans just really have to be
fans of us as people hey dude i'm ready
this is one of the most entertaining
[ __ ] videos that i've ever done this
is informational this is really
informational for me i am prepared right
now to go on the joe rogan program and
talk about how potassium
for three hours i'm ready to go
with studies with information with real
life stories from my friends and i think
everybody i think everybody would be
like yeah they're like okay that funny
moment where everybody in the comments
is actually like yeah my pajamas just
[ __ ] scammed me too that's gonna be
this video read the comments after this
i thought their main like thing was to
chalk people's legs off like when you
get gout and [ __ ] ah that's our main
thing right now that's that's pretty
important
your leg i think i thought it was just
like [ __ ] world war one they do like
arches and stuff like that like they do
that too yeah they do that's probably
scary it's doctor scholes you get the
doctor
shout out to doctor get the jellies dr
scholes doesn't mold to your feet
it does it does i think that's the point
squishy you got gel on there
that's the only catch it doesn't mold to
your feet though so but isn't it but
please buy it when you pay insurance
right that [ __ ] should cover it all i
paid 300 [ __ ] dollars a month and
that's like the second tier from the top
wow i used to pay the top one but i
never went to the doctor so i said
that's a [ __ ] waste of money right so
you pay 300 bucks a month you go to the
doctor and then you get the bill and
it's like this is how much it helped
cover you still got to pay 300 bucks
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was like that's too
much money yeah i don't think dr
scam there i think it's just the health
department in our country doctor soul
should be free infrastructure 100 free
dude yeah they pass out the condoms
they just look the same which one's the
condom
hey is vic's vapor or bad for you no no
it's great especially when you're
ecstasy i knew he was gonna say it and i
love it wait what is this what is this
what's with the e have you have you seen
the uh the element of two pack the nasal
one it's not the vapor rub it's like
that oh yeah dude you [ __ ] vapor rub
the [ __ ] out of your chest and then you
get a you get an n95 face mask and then
you [ __ ] rub the vapor and you go
like this or you get a construction
one's [ __ ] mess you know the one that
like you keep the saw that's not like
that
or if you feel crazy you stick both
fingers in the tub and then just put on
your eyes what the [ __ ]
you guys don't like white castle you
[ __ ] drug addicts
that was aggressive
you get the vapor up and you can just
even put it on the bottom right and then
you go like this and you tell someone
blow on your eyes it feels crazy someone
screamed captured that that was wild
that's real that's the real i think it's
funny because when you explain it to a
silver crowd that sounds ridiculous bart
20 something years me too it's just a
memory of mine that's a different life
was it you're talking about n95s that
was like reason
i'm trying to like 20 years ago during
my n95 i'm trying to make it relatable
he's bringing it back you know like
you're connected to the today
that's why you're a man of the people
that's you know
the people i'm pretty [ __ ] sure kids
right now raven are all wearing n95s at
[ __ ] electric daisy carnival and [ __ ]
because they don't want corona but they
also put maple rub in there and then
they [ __ ] breathe it dual purpose yep
they're all sharing vapor rubs and
they're all wearing masks
they hit my mask i love it i personally
love it how long would you leave it on
for as long as the menthol works
i kind of want to try that now i kind of
wanted to do a sober oh it'll kill you
what about a little bit though like it
just
will kill yourself imagine being in
antarctica oh can't do that already
and breathing that air that's what it
feels like
really really cool
oh relatable right can't wait to do that
and go to antarctica it's nothing like
this what a waste of a trip or it's
exactly like it
vixx
you